- Hello, everyone.
I'm Saad Omer, I'm the Inaugural Director
of the Yale Institute for Global Health.
I'm really delighted to
welcome you all to this event
of the global health conversation series.
In addition to YIGH,
which is our more sort of popular
name, the abbreviated name
of the Yale Institute for Global Health,
today's event is co-sponsored
by the Walker Fund
at the MacMillan Center at Yale.
Well, as you know that
the COVID-19 pandemic
has really catapulted the CDC
to the center of attention
with daily news stories
and everyday conversations
among the general public health.
Who would've thought that
there would be memes,
a lot of them positive, but
not uniformly so, on Instagram,
about the CDC, or there
would be TikTok videos
covering and talking about the CDC?
Well, with the focus that is there
on this government agency,
today we will reflect
on the work of the CDC,
including how this agency can evolve
to keep pace with the health challenges
the US and the world faces
and what it means to have
the microscope of the public
on this institution's decisions.
It is my sincere pleasure to
have three distinguished guests
joining us today, all of
whom are our former directors
of the CDC and esteemed
public health professionals.
And I will introduce each of
these panelists in a second.
Before I get to that,
I just wanna say that one the directors
is having some technical
difficulty in joining.
So Dr. Tom Frieden may join in the middle.
He may not be sort of
present at the beginning
of this session.
So starting with the introductions,
Dr. Jeffrey Koplan directed
the CDC from 1998 to 2002
and was a 26-year veteran of the agency.
He has worked on virtually
every major public health issue,
including infection diseases,
such as smallpox and HIV/AIDS.
In fact, when I was leaving Emery
where I was before coming to Yale,
he gave me a bifurcated needle
from the smallpox program.
I don't know if you remember, Jeff,
as a gift, as a souvenir.
He also worked on environmental issues
such as the global chemical disaster
and the health toll of tobacco
and chronic disease around the world.
Currently, Dr. Koplan is
a Senior Strategic Advisor
for what's called CHAMPS,
which is a program,
which is a pioneering program in assessing
the causes of childhood
mortality around the world
by using innovative methods
such as minimally invasive biopsies
and other similar approaches.
And he's also the PI of the
International Association
of National Public Health Institutes
and the Global Health Institute
China-Tobacco Control
Partnership at Emery.
He founded the Emery Global
Health Institute in 2006
and served as the Institute's Director
and as Emery's Vice President
for Global Health until 2021.
But I would say the coolest
thing about Dr. Koplan
is that he is one of our own,
and he did his BA from Yale.
And I forgot which college were you in,
I'll ask you when-
- Branford.
- Okay, good, wonderful.
And served on the Yale's
Board of Trustees.
And he currently serves
on the Yale Institute
for Global Health Advisory Board,
and continued to benefit from
his is public health wisdom.
The second CDC director
that I'll introduce
is Dr. Julie Gerberding.
Again, I'm going in sequence of their,
sort of chronological
sequence of their service.
Dr. Gerberding was also
a CDC director in 2000s.
I actually have, so
from 2002 through 2009,
where she led the agency
through more than 40 emergency responses
to public health crises.
She's the Executive Vice President
and Chief Patient Officer at Merck,
where she's responsible
for patient engagement
and advocacy population
health and similar tasks.
She joined Merck in 2010
as President of Merck Vaccines
and has just recently announced
that she'll be retiring
from Merck in May, 2022,
when she will become the
Chief Executive Officer
of the Foundation of the
National Institute of Health.
That's a very cool job, I guess,
in this scenario where undoubtedly,
like other public health agencies,
NIH will evolve after and
during the later phases
of the pandemic, and there
is a lot of excitement
around new leadership at NIH.
So in that function, I think,
I couldn't think of anyone more
suitable to be in that role
who has both government
and industry experience.
The third director we have as
our guest is Dr. Tom Frieden.
He was the director of
CDC from 2009 to 2017.
And look, CDC director is a cool job,
but I think in public
health, the coolest job
is the Commissioner of New
York City Department of Health.
I don't think it's one job
that is never boring, I guess.
And so his work made New
York City's TB program,
and overall health department's
models for the world.
And his initiatives around tobacco,
around trans fats, around
some of the other causes
of ill health, were
pioneering and were both,
and frankly, controversial at the time,
but in retrospect, a very well vindicated.
He established, before that,
effective programs in India
and improved morale effectiveness
and impact at the CDC.
He's now the president and
CEO of Resolve to Save Lives,
an initiative to prevent epidemics
and cardiovascular diseases worldwide.
He's a national and global leader
who has improved health
in the United States and around the world,
and is one of the world's
stop experts in TB,
Tobacco Control and Health
Policy and administration.
So, again, this is a
highly abbreviated version
of our guests' introduction,
but it really does give me
pleasure to have them come here,
albeit virtually and
engage in this discussion.
As I said, it's a
forward-looking discussion
about the CDC and US Public Health.
So the first question I have,
and the way this goes is that
I will ask a set of questions.
And then in the second
half of our conversation,
we will field audience
questions, et cetera.
So the first question is a
common question from each of you,
and we'll go in the same sequence,
starting with Dr. Koplan,
going to Dr. Gerberding
and then Dr. Frieden.
The question, Dr. Koplan,
is that when you were,
starting with you, when
you were the CDC director,
what was the biggest challenge you faced
and how did you respond,
and what were some of the lessons learned
from that experience
that are particularly relevant
now and going forward?
- I hope we have a couple
of hours to discuss.
The biggest thing, and Dr.
Gerberding knows as well as I am,
was heavily involved,
was the anthrax attack.
The first time an attack
of that scope and size
had been unleashed in the US.
And even though one might not,
the number of cases in
the number of deaths
doesn't compare with the current pandemic,
nevertheless, it was a
traumatic event for the country.
It was newspaper coverage,
front page every day for weeks.
It had CDC working very
closely with security agencies,
in particular, the Federal
Bureau of Investigation, the FBI.
And the scary thing
about it, at least to me,
was not only were we dealing
with a difficult lethal microbe,
but we had human intelligence
behind that microbe.
And makes it a little different
from naturally occurring events.
And in addition, it didn't take many cases
nor much effort on the
part of the perpetrator
to have the country in
chaotic, unstable situation
around this as a threat.
So that was an unusual, thank
goodness, unusual event,
and one that seemed to grind
to a halt of its own accord.
So because when we basically
had finished our investigation,
and we're still involved in parts of it,
nevertheless, there were
no new cases occurring
nor signs that the perpetrator
was off doing other things.
It reminds me, however,
of a common question
all of us have been asked at some time,
which is are we prepared?
It usually isn't modified,
would you say we're prepared
for public health threats?
Well, it really depends
on prepared for what.
Are we being prepared for
five letters in five mailboxes
in a couple of locations,
or are we prepared for 100s of letters
and 100s of locations
where they're deposited
and an ongoing threat that doesn't stop?
There's a big difference in response,
and it's a threat that
poses to many aspects
of the country's existence.
Things learned from that.
One is that you can't be over-prepared,
that what strikes next
may have characteristics
that are very difficult
to either categorize,
explain or control,
and yet we need to be
as prepared as possible.
But that includes a work,
and we'll get into this more,
that in something of
a colossal nationwide,
and then worldwide threat,
having a workforce that's
adequate to meet that.
And the wide range of skill
sets that are needed for it
is difficult.
And very few places have
anything approximating
such a workforce.
In addition, preparation
includes mock exercises,
role playing, and those that
were held were very helpful
and very useful, but that
needs to be an ongoing feature.
In terms of other aspects of it
that we can learn from,
the need for a skilled,
talented, dedicated workforce
emanating at the grassroots
level and counties
and small cities and townships,
and moving up through
state health departments
and then federal
governmental institutions,
that interface between those
different levels is crucial
in control of an outbreak
of almost any kind.
- Wonderful.
Dr. Gerberding.
- I'll just build on Jeff's comments.
And by the way, hello, from South Dakota.
I am having a little bit
of connectivity challenges
here in the hinterland.
So please forgive me if
I'm fading in and out.
I think our tendency is to gravitate
toward the infectious disease emergencies
or these urgent public health crises.
And I'll say a bit about that,
but I actually think
the hardest thing for me
as the director was balancing
those urgent imperatives
with the other health threats
that plagued people on an ongoing basis.
We came into the CDC in the
middle of an HIV pandemic.
We had dealt with an obesity pandemic
that continues to be a
global health threat.
So I think the challenge for leadership
is how do you make sure
that you don't neglect
the important issues that are longstanding
and go so far in the
direction of the acute crisis
that you really create
a public health system
that can't fulfill the
entirety of its mission.
And that's not just a
challenge at the CDC.
We are a system, we have
to include our states,
our counties, our local territorial
and tribal health departments
in this conversation,
as well as multiple partners
outside of those organizations.
And when we're talking about
preparedness or challenge,
it really, I can't think
of a single challenge
that we experienced at CDC
that wasn't also a
challenge on the front line
of public health somewhere else.
So that's a really hard situation.
I'm sure Tom will have
more to say about that,
'cause he's been on both
sides of that equation.
But for me personally,
I think clearly anthrax
was an incredible stress test,
but it helped us get ready for
the next big threat we faced,
which was the first SARS outbreak in 2003.
And fortunately, CDC
really, I think exemplified
the learning organization
under the leadership
of the National Center
for Infectious to Disease,
as well as Dr. Koplan,
when we established a whole
array of after action reviews
with virtually every set of stakeholders
that you can imagine,
from law enforcement to hospitals,
to college presidents
and so on and so forth,
really to learn and listen to
the panoply of stakeholders
that needed us to be
supportive and helpful
and provide some coordinating leadership.
So that outbreak, when
we were walking into it
was very ominous, because if you recall,
the mortality rate from SARS was about 10%
and we were seeing it
globalized overnight,
in the respiratory track
of a handful of travelers
that had all stayed in
one hotel in Hong Kong,
and from there, there was
a communal transmission,
as well as some significant
community transmission,
in some cases, mysterious
for example, in residential
facility in Hong Kong,
where I think to this day,
we don't exactly know how
the people were infected.
So many examples of how we
had to learn on the fly,
make decisions with insufficient data.
And when I've been watching CDC
and the public health system
in the context of our current pandemic,
I think one of the biggest
lessons I'm reminded of
is that what you see on the outside
and what's above the fold on the newspaper
does not tell the whole
story about what's going on
across our entire public health system.
There are absolutely heroic
decisions being made,
heroic data being gathered and
translated and promulgated,
guidance documents that are addressing
some of the most specific needs,
that, again, don't always make
the controversial front page,
but are actually important
to different sets of stakeholders.
So as we talk about how to make the CDC
or how to make our public
health system stronger,
we should also make sure to
be mindful of the strengths
that it does have and make sure we don't,
inadvertently, diminish those
while we are trying to solve
some of the longer-term
structural, financial
and workforce challenges that we face
in the modernization imperative,
I think is how I would put it.
So I'll stop there.
And as I said, I'm sure
Tom will be able to balance
the CDC view with the
New York City local view.
- Thanks so much.
Well, I agree with everything,
both Dr. Koplan and Dr.
Gerberding have said,
and I really appreciate the
last point Dr. Gerberding made,
which is it's easy to criticize
and it's often hard to do better.
And it's very important
when we're thinking
about public health,
meaning the public sector's
public health program
to realize what are the
constraints they work within
and what's the art of the possible
impairments of public health.
I'm gonna mention two
challenges that I faced.
One was the Ebola epidemic.
And that was massive.
I remember at one point
speaking to the incoming EIS officers,
and one of them asked, "What
percentage of your time
is on Ebola?"
And I said, "Well, I don't know exactly,
but it's certainly above 90%."
And that was the case for months.
When there was a case of
Ebola in Lagos, Nigeria,
that was the scariest moment
of my 7 1/2 years as CDC director,
because if it had gotten
out of control in Lagos,
it would've been all over
Nigeria, all over Africa,
not just for months, possibly for years,
and not just killing people from Ebola,
but shutting health systems.
So I remember putting
my hand on the shoulder
of one of our top control
experts and saying,
"You will be on the
flight to Lagos tonight."
And he was.
And we pulled all of our polio staff
and a number of other staff there.
And the team did a fantastic job.
The Nigerian team did a fantastic job
based on really the polio infrastructure
and the field epidemiology workers.
And they stopped the outbreak.
They stopped what would've
been a huge disaster.
A couple of months later,
we had a case in the US
that wasn't promptly diagnosed.
We had contacts, one of whom flew.
And it was a real mess.
We came in for heavy criticism.
Not every decision we made
was perfect, absolutely.
We made mistakes,
but we made the best decisions we could
based on the data that we had.
And I think that the
information that we conveyed
and the lesson that we learned
is that communication
is absolutely essential.
Tell people what you
know, when you know it,
how you know it.
Tell them what you don't know
and what you're doing
to try to find it out,
and give them practical,
concrete things they can do
to protect themselves, their
family and their community.
These are the principles
that Jeff and Julie wrote,
and we inherited as the principles
of emergency health communication.
Be fast, be right, be
credible, be empathetic,
be respectful, give people
practical, proven things to do,
because if you don't give
them practical things to do,
they will do other things
that aren't very practical.
And the second broad area,
it was tobacco control.
And here, this is what
kills the Americans.
And we were able to run hard-hitting ads.
We were not able to get the
Food and Drug Administration
to take some of the regulatory
action we wish they had.
But, if I can, I'll just
end with four big lessons.
One, speed is really important.
In Ebola, in Liberia,
we established something
called the rapid isolation
and treatment of Ebola
or the RITE strategy.
And we found that if we could intervene
in hours and days,
instead of days and weeks,
we could stop every chain of transmission
within three generations
within a month or two.
If we didn't, it might go
on for six or 12 months.
Second key lesson is
flexibility of funding.
CDC is hamstrung, 150
different budget lines.
I had literally 20 times
more flexible dollars
as New York City Health Commissioner
than I had as CDC director.
And when Ebola hit,
it happened to be the
end of the fiscal year.
And we actually had to borrow
$3 million from another agency
to pay plane tickets,
'cause we didn't have
that kind of flexibility.
Third is the global
nature of public health.
A risk anywhere is a risk everywhere.
We can't pull up a moat, and
certainly COVID-19 shows that.
And fourth, the importance
of policy change.
Policy change is the
royal road de progress.
And whether that's clean
water and clean air
or that's rapid data modernization
or that's any policy
aspect of public health,
it's very important to keep that in mind.
I'll stop there.
- Well, thanks.
This is wonderful.
And I was just gonna say that,
the playbook y'all wrote,
we teach that playbook,
communications playbook.
It it's out there.
And I wish this was more widely used,
especially in this
pandemic at various levels.
I will sort of search
things around a little bit,
because we are getting
a bunch of questions,
a lot of questions.
So I will go to an audience question.
And Dr. Koplan, this one is to you
and to continuing some of
the points that Dr. Frieden
brought up, what do you think about,
how do you work with CDC's
Washington DC Office to advocate
for an enact public health legislation
or public health policy?
Obviously CDC is an
Atlanta-based organization,
for those of us who don't know,
it's very much enmeshed
in the overall fabric
of that city, et cetera.
Obviously it's a federal entity,
but it's not a Washington DC entity,
which frankly, has been
leveraged fairly successfully
by a lot of leaders by making sure
that there is a bit of a separation
between the political
arm of the US government
and the sort of the technical
arm of the US government.
But setting that aside,
that has another dimension
about the sort of the DC Office,
and what are some of those dynamics
that can be leveraged?
Dr. Koplan.
- Thanks.
There's been a lot of discussion
about this over years,
that it's bad to be away from DC,
'cause that's where all
political action is.
Now person says it's
great to be away from DC,
'cause we're immune from
some of the politics
that goes on there,
that's not helpful to us.
The bottom line is you need both.
First of all, if you were to
wanna move CDC somewhere today,
you'd have a lot of
bricks and mortar on hands
as to where to put it,
and you'd be losing an
extraordinarily talented workforce
that is in place.
And I think largely thrives
by being a bit more distant
from the world of politics.
Having said that, leadership at the center
and in the department of
health human services,
needs a close interface
with CDC leadership.
So there's a Washington office
and I think it's developed
considerably over the years
and makes a big difference
that folks that are there
have often been on the hill before,
know a number of people and can cultivate
a bipartisan approach to
health and public health
that's really vital, if we're
gonna to be continuing improve
our outcomes versus the various
diseases that threaten us.
Having friends in the legislative branch,
of course in the executive branch,
are really important.
And that means they
need to be knowledgeable
about what we do and
knowledge about public health.
I think one of the problems
we are dealing with right now,
which is unfortunate drop in
respect for science in general,
for scientific institutions,
for the people that work in them,
is disastrous for the
wellbeing of the country.
That's not where growth is.
And growth and discovery and
application are what counts.
So for that to work, the
relationship with government
isn't going away.
We need to inform and encourage engagement
of elected officials in what we do
at the state, local and federal level.
And to have them as partners, moving ahead
with all the different pieces
that my colleagues have described,
whether they're chronic
diseases, non-communicable,
environmental, occupational,
as well as infectious.
All those need the support from the hill.
The folks in Atlanta do better
when the folks in Washington,
the elected officials
and the pointed ones,
in having respect for public health,
enthusiasm for what it's
accomplished and contributes
and become partners with us.
And that's occurred regularly
over the decades of the CDC.
Some elected officials
in the House and Senate,
take such pride in what CDC does,
that they've played a
role right alongside us
in getting things done.
And I think we'd all love to
see partners like that again.
- Wonderful.
Dr. Gerberding, when you
were the CDC director,
there was a pretty substantial
reorganization effort
to improved sort of the functioning of CDC
as an overall organization,
but with a specific focus
on improving preparedness
from various threats.
Nearly two decades later, and
in light of recent events,
any thoughts on further
restructuring or any lessons
that you can look back towards
that can inform CDC's future,
and broadly, public
health's future in the US?
- I'll just start by saying
something that Jeff brought up
in the beginning, and that
is anthrax taught us a lot.
It taught us scale.
It taught us intense
pressure and visibility.
It taught us the globalization.
A lot of people don't
know that some of the male
that was contaminated with anthrax spores
ended up in the diplomatic courier pouches
that went to a number of
embasies around the world.
That was kind of out of the news,
but a thing that was certainly on our mind
at CDC at the time.
And so the sequence of events,
it is hard to go back in time to 9/11,
and then the anthrax attacks
that followed shortly after,
and recall the mindset.
We had no reason to not
believe that anthrax
was somehow related to the 9/11 attacks.
So that did flex the
apparatus of public health
as well as our entire
government in a direction
that was much more focused
on the what if scenarios?
I think the good part of that
is that we did make some
substantive investments
that have had staying power
and have led to broad improvements
in our public health
preparedness across our network.
But the challenge is
sustainability of effort,
investment, and basically
leadership intent.
And we often characterize these decades
as periods of boomer bust
or complacency to crisis
to complacency to crisis.
So restructuring is not the solution
to anything that I've ever experienced.
I think that sometimes restructuring
can result in efficiency
or can create opportunities
to bring in a different kind
of talent or rearrange people,
but basically, the kinds of things
that are really necessary
to build a prepared nation
are some structural issues,
certainly budgetary issues,
that Tom has already mentioned.
And I think authorities
also come into this.
You may not realize that basically CDC
has essentially no authority to determine
what happens in the state or
a community health department,
and yet to really have an
effective cascade of protection,
whether we're talking about
emergencies or chronic problems,
we have to have a much greater
degree of harmonization,
integration of our data
systems, which currently
are bad as integrated
as a children's sandbox.
And we really have not been able to solve
for these foundational changes
that are necessary to truly modernize,
not just CDC, but the whole network
that has to come into play.
We saw this in the pandemic
where we couldn't get,
in real time, the hospital information,
or when we couldn't really
get vital statistics data.
And I'll refer you to
other resources on that.
But the failure to be able
to report the mortality
from the pandemic is not
because people in Atlanta
didn't wanna do it.
It's because the whole
network has to contribute data
in a uniform way.
Until the emergency
declaration was called,
we had no authority to do that.
So there are some very
specific authorities
and we have to start considering,
are we at a point in our evolution
where we need a national
public health system,
not a network of 3,000
plus independent entities
that cooperate,
but not necessarily in an
efficient or timely manner.
- Yeah, and I think it makes
a lot of public health sense
to at least think about this.
Obviously, it will have
pretty substantial legal
and even constitutional
implications because-
- And perhaps the 10th
Amendment would come into play
in this conversation.
But I think there are
still some things we can do
because we all want the same thing.
And when it's the right thing to do,
we have to think then
how do we reshape policy
so that we can do the right thing.
- Yeah, this is wonderful.
So Dr. Frieden, the next question for you,
again, it's from one of the,
actually one of the
reporters in the audience,
and they wanna know, do you
think the use of Title 42
is still justified in the
current public health context?
And is it appropriate,
now that the order has ended
for an company minors for
it to continue to apply
to families and adults
arriving in the US borders?
- Well, I don't wanna comment
on the policy issue there.
I thought you were asking
about Title 42 hiring,
which is a mechanism by which CDC
is able to pay competitive salaries,
and that certainly needs to continue.
(Saad laughs)
But that's a hiring policy.
I think the broader issue is
how do we, in public health,
keep faith with the American people?
How do we make clear that the
decisions that are being made
are made based on both the science
and the policy implications?
I think there's kind of a misunderstanding
of certain things.
When you say follow the science,
yes, the science will lead you so far,
but the science ends where a
community makes a decision,
and that decision might
be made differently
in different communities.
So at the same, let's
take COVID as an example,
at the same level of COVID
transmission in one community,
that community may decide
we really are concerned
and we're going to shut
restaurants, bars and churches,
and other houses of worship
until it gets to this level.
Another community may decide
our churches are so important to us.
We're gonna keep the churches open.
Another community may decide our bars
are so important to us.
We're gonna keep those open.
But fundamentally it's not
just a question of science.
It's a question of science and policy.
And CDC can inform the science,
but CDC doesn't set policy.
It's the us government that sets policy.
And I think if I can
reflect on what's happened
over the past five years,
there was an inappropriate
interference with CDC science
in the prior administration,
to the extent of folks at HHS
writing things on the CDC website
to be posted as if they
were CDC documents.
That's really inappropriate.
I said in one forum,
that's the equivalent of writing graffiti
on a national monument.
But somebody says if you write graffiti,
and corrected me and said,
if you write graffiti
on a national monument,
people know it's graffiti.
Here, people didn't know it was graffiti.
So yes, there's certainly
an inappropriate policy involvement,
but it doesn't mean that CDC sets policy.
CDC informs policy with science
and then a policy decision is made.
If that policy decision is so divorced
from where the science leads,
people at CDC may object,
they may quit, they may leave.
But generally, the way
policy decisions are made,
is there's a give and take.
And then a decision is made
and then people get on board to implement.
But for the specific
issues with immigration,
I think we need to see more rapid change
with things like travel guidance
and the issues are tough.
These are tough issues.
I can tell you when Ebola,
there was a case in the
US, second case in the US,
it was October, 2014, the
height of the midterm elections.
It was highly politicized,
calls for travel bans.
Very, very difficult to work
rationally in that environment.
- Yeah, no, I think that
that's a really great point.
Dr. Koplan, I know that
you have worked extensively
around the world and you have engaged
with collaborators in
China, fairly extensively,
and in this current environment,
which is increasingly
antagonistic between,
there's no other way to describe it,
between these two great powers.
What are some of the implications
of this kind of friction
on global health and
what is the way forward.
And both in the context of this pandemic,
it really sort of
surprises me that the US,
the engine of scientific
research and innovation
and China, the engine of manufacturing,
have this non-alignment of
mutual self-interest, it seems,
or when it comes to collaboration
around this pandemic,
irrespective of what else goes on
in terms of their own sort of domestic
and foreign policy priorities.
Any thoughts on that?
- Yes.
CDC has a history of
globalization, if you will,
of worrying about diseases that arise
in a different part of the
globe or threat spread,
and that there's value in
having a working relationship
with every geopolitical
entity around the globe,
'cause you don't know where
things are gonna start
or where they're gonna end up.
And I think our philosophy
of there's no written Bible
on this thing, is that work with people
who are like-minded with us
and who have something to gain
from making improvements
in health and healthcare
around the world.
And whether in past
decades it was the Koreas,
it was Cuba, it was Russia at
different times, et cetera.
But in terms of interface with China,
we work closely with
them for 30 plus years.
And we work with people
who have, every bit,
the same sincere,
concern, desire to improve
their health of them,
cells, their families,
their communities, their
neighborhood as we do,
and have things to offer
us that improve what we do
and we have things to offer
them that improve what they do.
So there are wrinkles in this.
We're not immune or oblivious
to what's going on around.
And that's unfortunate, that
there's more to be gained
by these two great power than not,
but that's well beyond our
tasks or responsibilities.
We can only do what we work in.
And when it comes to
working in public health,
we have a long track
record of working together,
coming up with solutions to problems,
improving the health of peoples there
and improving the health of peoples here.
But for the next pandemic,
if we go into this thinking,
there are enemies or
there are hostile labs
or we're hostile with them.
That may be true in some political layers
of the fabric of life.
But in terms of scientists,
public health workers themselves,
many have been here.
We know each other's
families, we work together.
We're not naive.
We know that problems can go
on even in these settings,
but we stand to lose much
more than we stand to gain
if we don't find ways to work together.
And it will pay off soon or later,
but it pays off to have
these common partnering,
partnerships in public health.
- So Dr. Gerberding, you
have a unique vantage point.
You have led a premier or
the premier in this country,
public health agency,
but also have been in the corporate sector
pretty for past several years,
and one issue, I know Merck is
not engaged in those debates,
but one issue has been
global vaccine equity.
Any thoughts on how we ensure
that in the next pandemic
we build systems and we build
public private partnerships
that ensure global equity in vaccines?
And I know Merck has
made certain commitments
of making some of the
treatments available earlier on
through proactive technology
transfer, et cetera,
but broadly speaking, rather than sort of
from the vintage point
of a single company,
what can be the structural triggers
policy makers can put in place
so that we have a more equitable response
in terms of vaccines and
treatments the next time around?
- Now, I'm really worried about it.
I don't think it's going
to be an easy solution set.
What we have observed in the pandemic
is well-intentioned
statements and commitments
that fall by the wayside when
the reality of the urgency
of the national demand takes precedent.
We've certainly seen that in the countries
that are making vaccines.
I think, perhaps one of
the most poignant examples
was Serum Institute of India
who had promised a
significant number of doses
to COVAX international consortium
to try to improve access to vaccines.
And then the Indian government
made the hard decision
that with the Delta outbreak there,
that they had to prioritize
the allocation of that supply locally.
There are some who believe
that having many more sites
of vaccine manufacturing
in many more countries
around the world would
be part of the solution.
And I don't disagree with that,
but I'm very familiar with
the scarcity of the resources,
both human as well as technical resources
necessary to manufacture a vaccine.
And I'm also well aware of
how hard it is to do it.
If it was easy, we would've
solved it a long time ago.
All you have to do is
look at the situation,
not in an international setting,
but in Maryland when emergent biologicals
was unable to successfully produce
the Johnson and Johnson vaccine
without encumbering
several quality issues.
So this is an area of science
that's not for the faint-hearted.
Over the long haul, we do need
to have a more global network
of vaccine supply.
And I hope that the platform technologies
will make that easier,
although I'm not too optimistic
that will happen fast.
People are naive in how they assess
the probability for that.
But I also am concerned that
our international institutions
are not strong and we
need global leadership
from the have countries
to be inclusive of have
not countries, so to speak,
in much stronger commitments
through the G-7, the G-20,
the governmental alliances.
And I would like to think
that the one of the lessons
we've learned is that we are only as safe
as the world is safe.
And so it's an enlightened self interest
to try to do more to create
equitable vaccine solution.
But as Tom and Jeff have both said,
we're also well aware of the politics,
particularly in an election year
or in a government transition period.
So these are really, really
difficult problems to address.
And it's not just a problem in a pandemic.
We see this problem for more
mundane problems as well.
One of the places where I think
we may be able to learn some lessons,
is from the Global Fund
as well as its intersection
with the World Bank.
That part of the opportunity
here is to leverage financing
so that we create the
mechanisms and the pull
to be able to require this
kind of global access.
And the last point I'll make
is I feel so strongly about it
is that as we're seeing
vaccine supply improve,
certainly not where it needs to be,
but certainly improved,
it isn't just about the number of doses.
It's about the systems
and the ability for people
to establish immunization programs,
which in most parts of the world,
there is no such thing as an
adult immunization program.
So to suddenly flex and try
to immunize, not infants,
but adults and teenagers of multiple ages,
that's a heavy lift in a crisis.
So if we're thinking about
how to improve supply,
we need to probably make
sure we don't forget
to improve the ability to distribute
and trust the value of the
supply that we are talking about.
Lots of work to do here.
I'm not trying to be pessimistic.
I'm just saying that,
I think I have a pretty
sober outlook on the lift
that we need to get together
and really try to support.
- Wonderful.
So the next question is actually
from a former New York
City Department of Dealth
infectious disease epidemiologists,
so actually I'll ask Dr. Frieden.
Well, I can ask either of you, any of you,
you are well qualified
to answer the question,
but I'll focus this one on you.
And the question is do you have any ideas
about how to rebuild and reinforce
the public health workforce post COVID-19?
There's a lot of burnout.
There's a lot of despondence in terms of,
despite a lot of hard,
there is a decline in trust,
and we have to recognize
that before addressing it.
And so one part is the overall workforce
from a health department perspective,
from a federal agency perspective,
but the other aspects of
the question I would add
is that often academic
entities don't do a good job,
and we have to be, or
at least as good a job,
and we have to be honest about,
is to be responsive to the
needs of applied public health,
for public health.
We shouldn't be in the business
of creating flexible needs
of tenured professors in
the field of public health.
We need to be in the business
of creating consequential
as public health practitioners as well.
And so any thoughts from that,
because you have led a
non-governmental organization,
a health department as well
as CDC, what can we do better?
- First, I think it's important
not to either under or
overestimate the problem.
Yes, people are exhausted.
It's been two years plus.
In many parts of the country and world,
public health has been quite
literally under attack.
And yes, there are a lot
of people who are tired
and have left the field
or considered leaving the field already.
It was an older workforce
that was nearing retirement.
That's why we created new programs
like the Public Health
Associates Program at CDC
to bring early career
people into public health.
I think first off, we
have to get the funding
for public health right.
This is crucially important.
As President Biden said,
when he was Vice President,
you show me your budget,
I'll show you your values.
And that's why we're advocating
for a health defense
operations budget designation
that would give people in
public health confidence
that it's not gonna be that boom and bust
panic neglect cycle.
It's going to be sustainable funding,
not just for their salaries,
but for the programs that they're running
so that they can rely on the
ability to start a program,
continue it and see it to
improvement and progress.
This is crucially important,
I think, on one hand.
On the other hand, I
think all public agencies
really need to think about
how to make the job rewarding
and safe for the workers.
And that means that you are
able to have and show impact,
that gives people huge satisfaction.
It is wonderfully inspiring
to work in public health,
but you have to be able to
see the faces and the lives
behind the numbers, because
the people whose lives you save
will not know that you saved their life.
So you have to be able to be satisfied
by the actual calculation
of what the impact has been.
You also have to continuously
upgrade people's skills.
We're all learning all the time,
and that makes jobs more satisfying.
And you have to have a work environment
that is supportive and
is able to contribute
to people's sense of personal worth,
of personal efficacy.
So I think, although there's
a lot of media attention,
and it's true that there
are a lot of people
who are tired and leaving public health,
it's also true, as you know,
that public health is very,
very popular as an interest
in colleges and universities,
that this can be a time of
public health renaissance,
where we diversify the field,
where we get into areas
that are more effective,
that we go deeply into communities
to identify as we do
in all of our programs.
What is the art of the
possible in each community
and each time.
And that becomes an
enormously satisfying job.
So I would say, by all means,
we have to keep people in
public health resourced,
safe, supported, part of a
broader network nationally,
globally, even.
And at the same time,
recognize that it is a wonderful career
with the opportunity to make a difference
and help to improve, protect,
save literally millions of lives.
- No, you're absolutely right.
And I sometimes say to
my students and trainees
that the easiest way to
avoid a midlife crisis
or existential angst that
a lot of people talk about,
is to go into public health.
The job of public health can
be frustrating, underpaid,
tiring, but it is never,
never, ever meaningless.
It is always what you do has meaning.
So I will sort of end, as
we come towards the end
of our conversation,
and I'll say that we are
getting a ton of questions.
I have not even asked
you 1/3 of the questions
we are getting, because
we have multiple streams.
I see a question streaming besides
because we are going on
Facebook Live as well.
And so I'm getting sort of questions
that someone is taking from there as well.
And then more direct questions as well.
So I apologize to our audience
for not getting to most of your questions,
but I don't think anyone wants
a three-hour sort of program.
But I will come back to the same format.
I'll ask the same
question from each of you.
CDC is a national treasure,
and yes, we need to recognize
that it's has taken hitch,
a lot of it unfairly,
but also a lot of lessons
need to be learned.
I'll tell you that we at Yale,
the Yale Institute for Global
Health did the first survey,
national survey of
attitudes in this pandemic
on February 8th, 2020.
And when we asked people,
who would you like to hear from,
in terms of the response, the top one,
not the president, not the NIH director,
well before Dr. Fauci
became a household name,
it was the CDC director.
People did not know the
name of the CDC director.
And so that's the cache,
the baseline cache CDC has.
And we can return to that.
The question I was asked most
frequently to ask you is,
each of you briefly, how do
we restore trust in the CDC?
So we'll go in the reverse order.
So we'll start with Dr. Frieden,
Dr. Gerberding and Dr. Koplan then.
- I think the CDC needs to speak directly
to the American people
regularly from Atlanta,
not part of a Washington
or White House briefing.
And trust is built teaspoon at a time,
and lost bucketful at a time.
So it's going to take time,
but success breeds success.
And the more CDC is able to do great work
and show the great work it's doing
that it hasn't been able to show,
I think it can steadily
rebuild that trust.
Julie.
- I agree with Tom.
I certainly think that the
credibility of anyone at CDC
is improved by communicating from the CDC
and not from a political institution.
But I also think that it's important
to realize that CDC is
not convincing the world
that the director is science-based,
or even that the CDC is science-based.
And I think we need to reflect
the public health system as a whole.
And so in addition to having the director,
who I think our current CDC director
is an outstanding spokesperson,
I think it's important
that we hear directly
from the scientists as
often as that's possible,
that they're standing on the podium
as information is being communicated,
that they address the
specific scientific questions.
But I also think it's important
that other public health
leaders in our network
are also part of the conversation
so it doesn't look like
something has come down
from the mountain and is being
disseminated to the valley.
But rather that our public
health system together is strong,
we're on the same page,
we're collaborating
and coming up with the
interpretation of the science.
But also as Tom said earlier,
the practical matters
and that when we stand together,
we can also explain why,
maybe we're going to
do one thing right now
in this community, and
a community over here
may be in a different situation
or have a different judgment.
And that's okay.
We're still all starting from
the same platform of science.
But it will be a long slot to build
the credibility of the CDC back up.
And I think that's where all of us
who are stakeholders in this need to help.
I think we can endorse the
things that have gone well
and try to be helpful and
constructive about the things
where we think some
improvement might be useful.
- Dr. Koplan.
- Yeah, just continuing what
Dr. Gerberding was saying,
at the best times in public health
has been when we have robust,
local and municipal and
state health departments
working well with federal partners.
And that's fallen apart a bit
and the need for commonality of interest
and a visible partnership,
right through the system
from grassroots to CDC director
needs to be re-instituted
in a way that people see it,
understand it and value it.
The point has been made
that there's a lot of,
a number of things went
wrong in this investigation
and probably will into the future.
We're dealing with a largely
unknown scientific entity,
have made great advances
in the course of it.
But as one hitches ahead,
we're not back 1000 on this
thing, nor will we ever.
I think the kind of attitude, nationally,
and it's not shared by
everyone, obviously,
nevertheless, takes, I think,
an unfairly critical look at CDC
in a way that doesn't
serve any of us well.
And if there's bath water
that needs to be thrown out,
fine, but be careful
what you're messing with
in the institution.
The institution has more
talented, brilliant,
contributing,
scientifically-monitored people
than any institution in the world.
And that includes distinguished
schools of public health
at universities, and it
needs to be nourished,
and it has to be seen
for its good aspects.
I think their attention's
gonna have to be paid
towards funding.
And that doesn't mean cutting funding,
it means providing sufficient,
predictable, flexible funding,
again, from the grassroots
level, right up.
The people on the field
need to be working closely
with CDC and vice versa.
CDC needs to be listening to folks
in state health departments,
and always has in the past.
Workforce needs to be improved,
new skills, focus on data and
analytics and communication.
And with it, is needed by
better pay and incentives
and increased diversity in the workforce.
It makes a difference in improvement
of programs and outcomes.
The data issues are real,
that they couple with the sciences.
Dr. Gerberding indicated and
Dr. Frieden has demonstrated
over and over again in his career,
but data drives things and
we need some common measures.
It's really inconceivable
that we're unable
to get common measures from
state to state, to federal.
This undermines what we're trying to do,
and that needs to be corrected.
Political influence has been mentioned.
It can be good, or it can be bad.
Let's try to play out the good parts
and value of politics in what we do.
Communication is
extraordinarily important.
CDC needs a top quality lead in that
and a office that is 21st
century in delivering messages,
experts in social media, et cetera.
So thanks, sure, this is
an opportunity to improve,
and a crisis like this, maybe
get something much stronger
at the end, we certainly hope so.
I think we are still in
the midst of a pandemic.
Going to the beach and not wearing a mask,
being in close quarters, lots
of things, are not history.
They're not part of the
past of this pandemic.
Unfortunately, they're
still part of the pandemic.
So they'll be an ongoing
key role for the likes of us
and other people in public health
and for its institutions.
And the more of those
institutions can do their mission,
the better off everybody
in this country will be,
and potentially in the world.
- Thank you.
With that, I'll close our session
and I wanna thank all
three of you for being here
and engaging in this conversation.
Hopefully, next time around,
we'll have the pleasure of hosting you,
either individually or
together as well in-person.
And you'll get the big
benefit of being in-person,
is that you get to interact
with the most inspiring
and smartest members
of the Yale community,
which is our students
and early stage faculty.
So with that, I'll close this conversation
and I'll remind our, sort of audiences,
that we stay tuned to the next
conversation series event,
which is likely to be equally exciting.
So appreciate all three
of you and everyone else
who has attended and those of us,
and members of the YGH team that help make
this conversation series possible.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much.
- Thanks.
- Take care.